hey what is up guys I'm qHD here and I
don't know if it's just me but it seems
like every press event I go to has
terrible lighting so to keep it
consistent this whole video will have
terrible lighting so just in time for
Android wear to become officially
compatible with the iPhone we get the
new Moto 360 it's official and it looks
pretty hot basically they took the old
one made a few improvements based on the
feedback we gave and made it a lot
better first of all there are now 3 main
versions of the Moto 360 watch itself a
small diameter a large diameter and a
woman's version small is 42 millimeters
woman's is also 42 millimeters but with
some specialized bands and material
options and the large is 46 millimeters
which is the same size as the original
now we're still rockin the same round
shape that got the Moto 360 its name you
might notice that bar at the bottom is
still there that flat tire it cuts off a
little tiny bit of the display yes but
it houses the sensors and it wraps
around the LCD a little bit but honestly
after using the original Moto 360 for so
long it's really not that much of an
issue to me anymore yes it would be cool
to have a full uninterrupted circle but
it's either that or bigger bezels and
Motorola is really proud of the Moto
360s huge screen to bezel ratio
everything else is slightly updated and
way more customizable as it's now in
Moto maker
obviously most smartwatches let you
customize it by picking a band moto
maker basically takes that to the next
level letting you pick a watch case
color the watch bezel color and the band
all separately so you can have actually
a color of the bezel independent of the
body which is pretty cool and there are
also band options available as you'd
expect and all these bands are quick
swappable so motorola made it pretty
easy to decide if you want to switch up
the look or you get a new band as a gift
or something you can use the lugs to
quickly pop off your current band and
attach a new one I did it myself with my
huge hands and it only took a minute the
women's version has slightly different
lugs but overall this brings the Moto
360 up to match other smartwatches like
the Apple watch in terms of making the
band switching easy I'm curious to see
how durable this connection with the
band's to the watch will be over time it
seems fine now and it was easy for me to
do in person but with a lot of bands
switch
it'll be interesting to see also moto
360 is now ip67 water resistant and dust
resistant meaning you can shower with it
if you want and they updated the
internal specs which was actually
concerned with the performance of the
old watch so now it's rocking a
quad-core Snapdragon 400 and Adreno 305
four gigabytes of internal storage and
half a gigabyte of RAM we still have a
heart rate monitor and we still have
wireless charging
but there is one speck that I am still
worried about and that is naturally the
battery and a SmartWatch it's a small
device they struggle with this usually
the Moto 360 now has a 400 milli amp
hour battery and the large version and a
300 million power battery and the small
and the woman's version on a large
version I was quoted at the event that
it'll get apparently two full days of
normal use but that's without ambient
mode on all I have to say about the
battery life until the full review is we
shall see overall I'm pretty pumped to
get my hands on the SmartWatch to use it
full time
it starts at $2.99 which is not cheap
for a SmartWatch or anything like that
but I'm willing to give it a shot
because the og moto 360 for so long was
my go-to SmartWatch oh and also there's
a sport version coming out later this
year as a sort of a separate device but
it has a built-in GPS and a unique new
display technology sort of combining a
regular LCD with a low contrast grey
reflective ambient display tech this one
will likely get its own review when it
comes out overall though got to admit
pretty pumped for the wave of second
generation smartwatches to start coming
out and this looks like a pretty good
start to that anyway
can't wait to customize want to use a
full time obviously thanks for watching
this first hands-on an impressions video
and I'll talk to guys the next one peace
you